hi I'm Felix but I'm probably better
known as purity pie and together with my
brows we just hit 25 million subscribers
that's amazing thank you both so much
in honor of hitting 25 million I thought
we were going to do something similar as
to when we hit 10 million which is do
something to help others so we're going
to start a new charity campaign for Save
the Children Save the Children is an
amazing charity that helps children all
across the world from Kenya to USA to
pull into Philippines to Sweden what
they provide is what every child out
there it is which is an healthy start an
opportunity learn and protection from
harm
I can even imagine what it would be like
growing up as a kid without any of these
things no matter where a child is born
or whichever situation she's and she can
still become anything from a farmer to a
doctor and to a YouTube gamer but they
need a surviving chance to get there
they need our help by donating to save
the children we invest in childhood and
we invest in a better future not only
for them but for all of us so I would
personally like to invite all of you not
only Broz but all of us together to be a
force for good so please go ahead and
check out the link in the description or
the text that shows here by donating
five dollars to give a family of five
bread rations for an entire day also if
you include the hashtag gross Save the
Children on Twitter you enter in a
chance to play some games with me yeah
there's a ton of more cool stuff like
that on the websites be sure to check it
out you could have a tool enhance Skype
chat me you can get some foodie pie
signed and phones and other
I really really hope you bros will join
in on this we need all the help we can
get big or small and our goal is to hit
250 thousand dollars which I know it's a
lot of money but I also know together we
can do it I will be donating as well of
course and I pledge to donate one dollar
for every thousand views this video will
get so please feel free to share this
video around with people for extra
support my maximum is twenty five
thousand for hitting twenty five million
every share and every dollar counts
grows there's no ads on this video or
any funny business like that and the
IndieGoGo page is set up by Save the
Children themselves so all the money
goes straight to them and it's a
certified charity page please right now
go ahead if you haven't already check
out the link in description or make your
donation today thank you so much you
guys are the best
brofist by donating $5 which
so heist you laugh in the background